on va passer tout de suite au jeu turc
ont fini c'est très sain on va vous
poser des questions sur l'actualité vous
avez joué avec nous bien entendu un
point par bonne réponse le chroniqueur
qui obtiendra le plus de points
désignera celui qu'on sortira de la zone
rouge et qu'on enverra à plus de 100 km
ce soir oui soir juste après l'émission
et bien sûr pour partir en toute
sécurité le chroniqueur partira dans sa
bulle de protection
regardez il partira dans une bulle de
protection à 100 km voilà on regarde
voilà
et voilà donc voilà je vous le dis
attention donc répondez bien soyez bon
c'est parti question ces parties où on
va envoyer le king le ch de recompiler
on est en direct c'est la fête ou dingle
il arrive mais il est aussi à rungis
[Musique]
[Rires]
voici le jeu
[Musique]
et
on n'a pas du tout l'argent donc en soi
or des génies à bien les missions vers 6
heures franchement c'est drôle sinon on
n'a pas mis tout l'argent de ses moyens
mamie qui marmonne un ingénieur j'adore
ça c'est qu'est ce qui se passe à
souilhe bon soir qui adore ce générique
mais pourquoi vous êtes où celle ci elle
nous appelle doigt les viandes et les et
elles viennent césaire et à l'allemand
ce générique qui alors pourquoi vous
êtes là bas alors racontez nous
pas pour rire en grappes pour rire en
groupe puis quand j'aime bien dans le
décor dans cette science est à oublier
je ne sais pas mais peuvent avoir un sms
mais vous parlez des gros salaires donc
me suis pas senti concerné vraie voiture
et vous avez bien raison à l'ailé
thierry question qu utilise une école
marseillaise pour faire respecter la
distance de sécurité benhaim une règle
une affiche de fabien lecoeuvre en
taille réelle
un cerceau ou un bras en plastique je
vais dire je vais dire un grand
plastique un bras en plastique
cette semaine un des évènements du
déconfinement c'est la réouverture des
écoles
alors tous les écoliers ne reprendront
pas en même temps vous le savez il ya
les écoliers qui vont reprendre plus
tard il ya les petits écoliers qui sont
déjà en boutique il ya une école qui a
trouvé une solution
ce qu'à marseille ils ont fabriqué un
uniforme on tique ovide 19 regardez
c'est assez malin et ils valérie bénaïm
une fois de plus vous êtes à côté de la
plaque alors qu'une partie des élèves de
maternelle et primaire ont fait leur
retour dans les classes aujourd'hui les
établissements de france ont chacun
organisé à leur manière ce retour à
l'école dans le respect des
gestes-barrières pas facile pour les
enseignants de faire respecter les
mesures de distanciation sociale mais à
marseille une école semble pourtant
avoir trouvé une astuce pour permettre
aux enfants de prendre l'air sans
toutefois se mettre en danger en effet
les responsables de l'établissement eut
l'idée d'attaché des cerceaux de couleur
à défiler pour délimiter l'espace vital
de chaque enfant et ainsi éviter au
maximum les rapprochements et donc la
propagation du virus c'est le directeur
de l'école michel lopez qui a eu cette
idée insolite
je regardais les affiches de prévention
les personnages sont entourés par des
cercles rouges pour symboliser la
distanciation
j'ai tout de suite pensé au cerceau un
outil ludique pour apprendre aux enfants
la distance si tous les élèves de
l'école se voit porter cette tenue
les élèves de cm2 pour y échapper
puisque jugé plus mature et en âge de
comprendre les gestes barrière
et franchement quand on vous pose la
question bonnes ou mauvaises idées oui
bonsoir m'avait vue sur quelques vidéos
des marchés au début du confinement avec
des messieurs qui se baladent avec des
cerceaux tombe bien ce qui donne au
final c'est une super bonne y va c'est
fou et en corée du sud il porte un
casque de carnaval avec une règle comme
ça comme ça ils peuvent pas toucher les
gamins d'accord vous êtes parti en corée
du sud n'ont pas encore saisi 1
n'hésitez pas quelqu'un peut réagir oui
bonsoir oui elle est bien debout seul
séisme
elle a ri corps est alors alors regarder
non non si on a en chine ont regardé
comment ça se passe en chine
il regarde pas du tout avec le retour à
l'école sont vraiment à fond regardez
par quoi doivent passer les élèves avant
d'entrer dans l'école c'est chaud
regardez c'est chaud
[Musique]
ça se passe comme ça en chine way we
valérie pas tous les enfants sur les
enfants de ceux qui sont font partie de
l'élite voilà exactement partie et ils
ont droit à ce traitement là d'accord
comme ça dans toutes les écoles merci
valérie bénaïm bien sûr c'est que de la
télé toujours une bonne info les raisons
de minutes je suis en clientèle j'arrive
oui nous sommes je suis en clientèle oui
bonsoir qu'est-ce qui se passe et vous
avez vu que lille désinfecte même la
bouche des enfants ahmed ils dominent
utah je suis à bout c'est pour un
abonnement même si vous effectuez la
bouche si le virus tueur en toiture sur
ta est un virus et les comme le tigre va
tout est en toi mais je te le dis
qu'elle forte odeur as mais pas pour
vous la panique chez de nombreux
habitants de la région parisienne hier
une odeur de boulettes au dessus de chez
benhaim une odeur de soufre dans l'air
une odeur de brûlé dans le métro où une
odeur suspecte dans le slip de bagira
castaldi contrairement à valérie je
travaille on les émissions je dirais
réponse b l'odeur de soufre dans l'air
exactement une mystérieuse odeur de
soufre bien entendu a été sentie à paris
et dans plusieurs autres départements
d'ile-de-france pile au moment du des
confirmands cette odeur inquiétait
beaucoup de monde ça fait énormément
réagir on a vu on a eu des théories de
fous se répandre sur les réseaux sociaux
encore une fois aujourd'hui on sait
toujours pas avec certitude à quoi cette
odeur et du on vous explique tout ça et
les différentes pistes bien entendu je
vais en quête cette nuit je donnerai des
conclusions normalement demain matin
première heure on regarde alors que les
franciliens s'apprêtait à organiser leur
première journée de d confiné hier soir
c'est finalement un autre événement qui
a occupé leurs fins de week-end tenter
de comprendre l'origine de cette étrange
odeur qui envahit une grande partie de
l'île de france
hier dimanche 10 mai sur twitter
nombreux étaient les internautes inquiet
de cette forte odeur de soufre ressenti
à paris et sa région si certains ont
très vite cherché du côté d'un possible
accident industriel très vite les
autorités ont balayé cette hypothèse le
premier adjoint à la mairie de paris
emmanuel grégoire se voulait hier soir
assurant à ce sujet aucun incendie ou
accidents industriels n'a été signalé
très vite de nombreuses théories du
complot ont fleuri sur la toile guerre
bactériologique traitement contre le
comique 19 accidents chimiques dans un
pays voisin non déclarés mais pour les
autorités et les météorologues
l'explication serait tout autre en
réalité il s'agirait d'une odeur lié aux
récentes intempéries comme le suggère
pierre perron porte parole d'air paris
au regard des conditions météorologiques
très dispersive devant il est possible
qu'une pollution de rentrer locale
provenant éventuellement des structures
d'assainissement des eaux et lieux et
était senti à plusieurs endroits si
cette odeur reste donc pour le moment en
partie un mystère selon les différents
relevés de la qualité de l'air réalisé
hier soir cette odeur ne représenterait
aucun danger pour la population
voilà on en a tous entendu parler de
cette odeur de soufre vous également
oui et mon mari chimiste est d'accord
avec leur expliquer c'est à dire qu'est
ce qui dit votre mari s'il est comme eux
bah qu'est ce qui dit il est comme eux
que c'est lié la peau la lutte la flotte
et les inondations ont fait macérer tout
tout un système est remonté de la
pollution j'en avais parlé avec votre
mari chi on parle de tout dans les
séries docquiert vous avez vous a dit il
à il vous a dit alan et vous a dit quand
il entend avant même que donne
l'explication est lisse et sans doute
atteint et c'est ce qu'on a vu ensuite
sur l'écran sur son mari chimiste maryse
mais c'est la première fois qu'il
pleuvait à paris pour qu'il s'en tire sa
juste alors je vous dire non parce que
en fait je vais demander votre mari
chine c'est le joignable non parce que
ça faisait je pense très très longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu de fortes pluies de ces
peuples humains là et forcément quand la
pluie très très forte le soufre bien sûr
de l'importance d'épargner des groupes
bassins de décantation où les liens sur
des centres de traitement
l'effort de pure ou au bras c'est cette
eau et du coup fait remonter les odeurs
qui sont principe sous l'eau qu'ils ont
faits remontent à la surface et d'amitié
dans la glace en moins parce qu'on a
plus de pollution est là quand même
moins de pollution à paris on le sent
plus même si vous avez un mari chimiste
[Rires]
merci mais naim on se passera de
commenter en vous adore kelly mais de
béni avec kin one a tenu son premier
enfant son gynécologue son
musicien son agent ou son livreur hubert
it's à son musicien son musicien c'est à
dire son musicos quoi elle est en couple
avec florian aussi mais oui il a le nom
d'un joueur de foot et pourtant c'est un
musicien a rencontré sur une de ses
tournées ils ont décidé de passer
l'étape supplémentaire en devenant par
an regardez c'est bon quoi
elle est jeune et belle c'est magnifique
merci en tout cas vous dites des belles
choses oui je sais ça fait du bien d
confinement des saisons 1 celui qu'on
retient voilà une chanson que peut
aujourd'hui chanter luan qui vient tout
juste d'accoucher de son premier enfant
voilà des mois que les fans de la
chanteuse attendait la bonne nouvelle
alors qu'elle s'était montrée avec son
ventre arrondi en janvier dernier lors
du défilé jean paul gaultier à paris à
23 ans la chanteuse découverte dans the
voice vient tout juste d'être maman
le père de l'enfant n'est autre que
florian aussi un musicien qui a
collaboré aux tournées de stromae kenji
ou soprano et qui depuis 2010 8 a
rejoint celle de luan c'est donc sur les
routes que les deux artistes se serait
rapproché un rapprochement qui donnent
aujourd'hui naissance à une petite fille
qui se prénomme isabelle un hommage à la
maman de luan disparu en 2014
autre bonne nouvelle la naissance du
deuxième enfant du couple deux boxeurs
tony yoka et estelle mossely le petit
magomed aînés de 7 mai dernier sur
twitter le champion a exprimé sa joie
notre deuxième fils magomed rocha est né
jeudi 7 mai 2020 merci estelle mossely
et félicitation encore une fois un
accouchement comme une championne toutes
nos félicitations à ces enfants qui
auront apporté un peu de joie alors par
an durant ce confinement
et luan qu'on va retrouver ce soir dans
la famille besnier juste après c'est que
du kif ce sera à 21h10 direct n'y aura
pas de pub ça va se déchaîner
comme on est comme des friandises oui
bonne soir non je disais qu'elle était
jeune et jolie parce que c'est important
de le dire quand les gens sont jeunes et
jolies et qu'il le mérite parce qu'elle
s'est quand même pris beaucoup dans la
tronche des réflexions sur ségo sur ses
rondeurs et même avant qu'elle soit
enceinte et j'ai trouvé ça tellement
injuste et tellement dégradants et
gratuit parce qu'elle est magnifique que
je tenais à le dire qu'elle était jolie
et bien écoutez vous savez quoi
quand il ya des gens comme ça qui n'ont
pas peur de dire les choses moi je dis
bravo
non mais franchement qui voit là c'est
quelqu'un cas pas peur de poing des
risques bordel de merde voilà donnée aux
cas on est dans quelle société
bon les séries on va continuer notre jeu
dans un instant qui va entrer en bulles
chez lui on va j'ai trois questions pour
vous regardez voilà yabby you lie il ya
bien sûr le fils de chevalier laspalès
il ya raymond verdure cayla qui lui qui
est là qui est bien sûr vous savez qu'il
est maître chien également le plein pour
l'instant mauvaise réponse bonne réponse
bonnes réponses qu'on passe à maxime
gainey maxime guennoun de chez les
tunisiens keller idée originale à une
enseignante américaine pour faire
plaisir à ses élèves pendant le
confinement elle donne des cours déguisé
en reine des neiges
elle distribue des bonbons à la
chloroquine elle fait les devoirs à la
place des enfants ou à la fabriquer une
combinaison peut faire des câlins c'est
plutôt la réponse des en a besoin
d'amour comme il avait les rires ouais
j'ai besoin d'amour
merci longtemps la première heure après
tu te dis bien qu'il soit rare qu'on
finit quoi regarder
[Musique]
regardez regardez les chiens de garde et
je peux le faire
regardez je peux faire un là je peux
faire un câlin voilà je peux faire
gardien mon maxi bien faire un câlin mon
chéri j'ai l'impression que c'est un
merci qui veut aller là bas finalement
dont un tiers faite vocal un terme à
venir parce que j'ai je vais pas faire
des câlins tout le monde j'ai pas envie
de me rattraper des maladies jean michel
basquiat le permettre c'est trop tard
vous y avait là si on enlève merci bravo
réussi de chance on appris j'y travaille
la bienvenue mr si brigitte brigitte
raoult la fille du professeur à ou merci
brigitte bonnes réponses sur tout cas de
maxime guennic 1 vous bonsoir comment
allez vous
jusque là tout va bien alors merci
isabelle morini bosc qui fait son retour
sur un plateau c'était très très
attendue elle n'avait pas mis les pieds
sur un plateau depuis 10 812 question
utilise la ville de singapour pour faire
respecter la distanciation social dans
un des ces parcs
un drone qui balancent des jets de
peinture un pigeon qui défèque sur les
gens trop moche un robot chien qui aboie
un message d alerte ou à haut-parleurs
avec la voix de gilles verdez qui dit
j'ai mal à mes chaises ne va rien alors
je dire
tu rêves tél ouais vraiment y être bonne
dans l'actualité
ça dépend de ce que je bosse avec il ya
une élection après alors je dirais
qu'ils aboient un message dans l'ère du
dirais je dirais là c'est là c'est moi
lassé et non fallait encore une mauvaise
réponse si on va regarder si je crois
que c'est la bonne réponse monde isa
bravo ma chérie on me voir je vérifie ce
que vous êtes torv menon
[Musique]
voilà est bonne réponse oui si les
couacs et si oui bonsoir moi je pense
que c'est hyper dangereux s'il fait un
gros pas de courir pendant un peu
mcgrath avait beaucoup bu pendant le il
ya 20 min bah oui bonsoir kelly je
préférerais qu'on paye des gens pour
pour le faire et qui avec les licences
de sécurité parce que ces trucs là je
trouve que ça va ça m'est vraiment race
race et ça me fait peur mais si je vois
ça dans la rue moi c'est ouais là bas
quand vous habitera singapour vous
pouvez leur dire puisque pour les ans
c'est assez des fois ya des choses qui
arrivent en france alors alors pour que
ça arrive de singapour en france surtout
en ce moment avec le confinement je peux
vous dire que c'est pas ma appareils les
chéris oui qu'est ce qui se passe est
une bible les plus propres du monde
parce que le serment de son terrible
c'est vrai je tâcherai comme par terre
c'est 1500 euros d'amendé
y'a un mec je vous dis moi d'assumer
mettre des humains la plainte et
machines non mais chaque vie est unique
dans la rue à saint andré offrant 50 tôt
là bas je peux tenir et de composer luis
salom et il te couple c'est oui oui
c'est 'qui a mais je te le dis tu te
retrouves circoncis là je peux bien ils
sont des rats dans la bassin gapeau
éliminables des tables est arrivé colère
je crois pas ça déconne pas la main à
travailler tant la cia même ils le font
même leur font le 5 à 10% en direct et
en même temps de ma mère je connais très
bien je connais très bien
tiens question pourrait manquer pour
vous vers le bas du dos avec nous quelle
est la particularité de cette femme est
égoïste
ça n'a rien à voir avec la soi disant
ouais choix multiples et moi je me mens
alors je vais te la donner à la les plus
grosses marines du monde
elle a les plus grosses rêve du monde
elle a plus de mouchette de moustache
que cheb khaled ou à la 58 dont elle
allait la baie elle a les plus grosses
lèvres du monde a les plus grosses
lèvres du monde eh bien on va regarder
et raymond apparemment tu es pas le
dernier pour donner les bonnes réponses
dans la juno lecture hernie sportive
pareil dans la bulle la meuf est la meuf
elle tombera ce elle te débouche la
gueule lt shot ils sont énormes et son
honnêteté toilettes qui sont bouchés tu
n'envoies frère de fête passage s'est
dit que là elle avait en direct leurs
missions rigoler on irait qu'alain
zodiac ou b la lèvre et la maman alors
malheureusement là on rentre dans une
pathologie psychologique que physique
son problème c'est que là les rentrer
dans une spirale où malheureusement elle
va pas bien dans sa tête et plus elle en
fait mieux s en est malheureusement plus
à la dgrad elle est rentrée dans la
ville la plus à moi je me rappelle moi
j'étais eux
bonjour à tous moi j'étais alors bernal
un seul mâle ce mot sera la rage me
disent que moi spirale ma terrorisme
ah bon pourquoi parce que je me rappelle
quand je veux passer le permis en fait
moi j'étais j'étais très nerveux au
volant n'est pas qu'on vole en automne
et j'avais un prof de trucs et me dire
comment il a raconté il y avait un
accent je me fais écoute là je vois
coûte cyril je vais te le dire au niveau
de la conduite tu es dans la spirale de
l'échec
cependant le truc et vous savez ce que
je sais plus jamais revu ces partis sont
répartis de la voiture périph c'est la
voiture et maintenant nous jure que
c'est vrai qu'une partie jeudi cc pense
qu'il vaut mieux non je dis je pense
qu'il vaut mieux qu'on arrête de se
parler il parlait albert mais vous
l'avez du premier coup ou pas - il
parlait qui est pas certain mais vous
l'avez mérité dans la spirale de l'échec
ces failles du premier mois la question
tu peux pour tout le monde là une bonne
question pour quelle raison un enfant de
cinq ans a été arrêté aux états unis
il a braqué une usine de mlm le chocolat
champions le madame tussauds il
revendait du gel hydroalcoolique à la
sortie des classes
il a pris l'autoroute pour aller
s'acheter une lamborghini ou il
téléphoné à ses voisins pour faire
d'études à vue qui bon qu alan bangui
l'abbé d'organes et de lamborghini
l'embarras regardez voilà quoi c'est
quoi l'histoire
ben ali leïla bouffe j'allais je n'ai
pas vu mais il n'est pas manger des
gâteaux dcdm nfc bmc d'accord les
chocolats etc ou chocolat avec de la
cacahuète exactement reis wikileaks et
ça c'est bon les ménisques sp sol a
fallu qu'on a pas de réponse réponse est
bonne à link la raison regardez vous
pensez que votre enfant est capricieux
attendait de voir ce qu'il en est de ce
petit américain
ce jeune enfant de 5 ans originaire de
l'utah avait un rêve posséder une
lamborghini si c'est le rêve de nombreux
garçons de conduire un bolide de sport
quand ils seront grands
cet enfant là n'avaient visiblement pas
le temps d'attendre sa majorité pour
obtenir l'objet de tous ses désirs
après avoir demandé à plusieurs reprises
à sa maman de lui acheter la voiture de
ses rêves face aux nombreux refus de
cette dernière il a décidé de se
débrouiller tout seul en demandant à son
papa au père noël en brûlant un siège
non en volant les clés de la voiture
familiale et en allant lui même la
chercher jusqu'en californie
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître à cinq ans seulement il a
réussi à faire démarrer la voiture
familiale et à conduire plusieurs
kilomètres sur l'autoroute en direction
de la californie qui notons le se trouve
un peu plus de 1000 kilomètres de là sur
la route des policiers ont observé une
voiture roulant dangereusement au milieu
des deux voies très vite
en s'approchant du véhicule les
policiers sont étonnés lorsque l'agent
morgan s'est approché à pied de la
portière du conducteur il a trouvé
étrange de ne pas pouvoir apercevoir la
tête du chauffeur depuis l'arrière filmé
par la police elle même la voiture
roulait tout de même à vive allure plus
fou encore lorsque le policier a mis sa
sirène tout de suite l'enfant a eu le
réflexe de se mettre sur le bas côté
après vérification l'enfant a pu être
raccompagné chez lui très déçu de ne pas
pu avoir acheté la voiture de ses rêves
avec l'argent qu'il avait mis de côté à
savoir 3 dollars une histoire à peine
croyable comme il en existe qu aux etats
unis
c'est complètement fou ça et la musique
et d'entamer ces cas là les gens qui
connaissent le produit est vraiment cool
et au tchad se la payer en francs ouais
c'est le temps que je vous ai déjà volé
la voiture doit pas vous absolument pas
moi j'étais vous savez une évoque très
sage il a bien volé votre voiture
bah je ne crois pas vous croyez pas tom
qui s'appelle ses partiels en ce moment
parce que les partiels bien sûr à 45 ans
le fils de beinheim bien sûr qui a eu le
bepc encore l'année dernière vous oui je
n'ai déjà volé mes doigts la campagne ça
se fait régulièrement ce qu'on conduit
très jeune à la con moi j'habitais dans
les vosges
voilà il prendre la voiture c'est pas
quelque chose qui est délictueux
évidemment la campagne on croise peu de
voitures et cetera c'était en hiver et
angie vous permet à acheter pour aller
de faire des travaux forestiers et voilà
j'ai roulé pour retrouver une amoureuse
j'avais 14 ans à peu près je me souviens
je suis arrivé les habiter à 10 bornes à
peu près mais j'avais comme disant 10
doute 12 ans tous raison et je suis
arrivé j'avais des bras comme ça ce
qu'avec le froid je pouvais plus bouger
les bras comme ça bah merci en tout cas
vous raconter de bien belles anecdotes
sur michel non mais c'est vrai un seul
regret que vous avez déjà volé le
tracteur parce que moi j'ai horreur de
tout ce qui roule ça j'aime bien me
faire très charrier si j'ose dire
d'accord donc ma revanche je suis monté
sur les tracteurs 8,1 campagne j'adorais
un agriculteur andré doré les dents de
sabre accord avec lui ah ouais et vous
allez il m'a pas là vous dis là rien
labour est avec moi il m'a pas labourer
non plus donc voilà reparti en reste et
a mis d'accord c'est quoi l'amitié
dursin certainement plus souvent plus
longtemps que l'amour garder benhaim et
moi et dieu sait qu'elle a eu envie que
la foulée